President Trump is blasting China head
of a series of meetings in Europe where
the North Korean threat will certainly
be discussed the president left
Washington a short time ago he will
visit Warsaw Poland before the g20
summit in Hamburg Germany in a tweet
before he left this morning the
president claimed that China's trade
with North Korea jumped this year and
wrote so much for China working with us
but we had to give it a try major
Garrett is in Warsaw where the president
arrives this evening major good morning
good morning the president will receive
a warm welcome here and is anticipating
an enormous crowd for his speech
tomorrow on the future of the u.s.
polish strategic alliance that speech
will also touch on something known as
the Warsaw Uprising the largest
organized protest against Nazi Germany
throughout all of Europe during World
War two an uprising that was mercilessly
crushed by the Nazis but is something
that poles take very seriously and the
president wants to commemorate while
here the president will also meet with
the leaders of Poland and Croatia with
an emphasis on protecting so-called
frontline States threatened by Russia
there is a hope throughout Eastern
Europe mr. Trump while here will
reaffirm NATO commitments to defend any
nation that faces aggression the
president then leaves for Hamburg
Germany and the g20 summit a big topic
there North Korea's intercontinental
ballistic missile test that will include
a meeting between the president and
Chinese President Xi Jinping president
Trump has tried to encourage China to
intervene with North Korea but the
results have been mixed at best
another huge meeting President Trump's
first encounter with Russian President
Vladimir Putin administration officials
say there is no formal agenda and will
be determined to Jeff entirely by quote
whatever the president wants to talk
about major Garrett thank you very much
in Warsaw